this was big for me but i went up to her
and i said if i see
you talking to him and i said these
words verbatim
the [ __ ] is going to hit the fan
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your
roast coming queen a girl who convinced
her parents to name her dog
knoxville after johnny knoxville without
telling them
what it was about elise morales and with
us today guys we have such a funny
comedian she's a stand-up she's a writer
you've seen her on comedy central you've
seen her all over the place her one
woman show it's christy [ __ ] was like
my favorite
thing in the world but before all of
that
she was a graduate of pilgrim high
school
it's kristy cello
yay hello thank you so much for having
me did you really name your dog
knoxville
mm-hmm i loved that i loved i know
and can i say when we had stevo on this
podcast
i chickened out and i didn't tell him
because i just felt like
i felt like it wasn't the vibe and i i
was like i think that if i tell him this
he's gonna think it's really weird
maybe next time it's a great name for a
dog
no it comes to him but it's a really
good dog name
it really was and um it like led a lot
of people to ask us questions because
they would be like
oh so are you guys from tennessee and my
parents be like no
we're from new jersey like
this is actually apparently a show that
our 13 year old daughter is really into
where guys staple their dicks to each
other
oh god it was such a defining show of
of my teenage years and apparently yours
too even though i think i'm a lot older
than you though
i think i'm 30. okay i'm third i just
turned 35.
so not not that much but it's but i
you know it is a different relationship
to have
with jackass when you're 20 versus 15.
yes so i it was very subversive
for me to be into jackass and i uh
i wanted them all to be my boyfriend
why was that the response that i was
having to what they were doing
and this makes me feel so old because
now i just look
back especially at like bam or jarrah's
show and i just think about how
badly i feel for his parents like when
he was constantly pranking them i
thought it was so funny at the time and
now i look
back and think oh my god like they
didn't ask to be on the show
yeah like like this woman's coming home
to like an alligator in her house
she's just like a woman oh i was so in
love with bam margera and i remember i
got in trouble
in um in eighth grade because
i did we had to do a presentation on a
sport
and i picked skateboarding
cool because i'm [ __ ] cool
so i picked skateboarding so that
everyone so that i could telegraph to
everyone that like i'm not into sports i
don't know about sports i like
skateboarding even though i could not
skateboard
so you didn't even know how to
skateboard no
no one christmas my dad bought me a
skateboard that was called
skater in a box
like skating for dummies
oh my god and i learned how to like go
down my street on it and then i kind of
got to the point where it's like
you get to a point where you're gonna
have to commit to falling down and
hurting yourself
and i just couldn't commit to that uh
but i did a presentation on
skateboarding and i included a picture
of bam
in my little like presentation and his
pants were
like down really low so you could see
like the v
of his croc and i got in trouble and i
got told that i had to take it out of
the prison
really and it's funny because it didn't
even like really serve
was it just because he was hot like it
was just like oh i just thought it was a
cool picture of bam
i like hadn't even noticed that and then
my teacher like came over
and was like you put like a sexual image
oh my god and i was just like no this is
just a picture of
bam that i got on the internet i didn't
even
maybe your teacher was your teacher a
guy or a girl girl
maybe she was she was looking she was
the real person who was looking at his
[ __ ] gutter
examiner that's like on that
area she was the horny one exactly
that's on her she basically came up to
my desk and was like your presentation
made me horny
how am i supposed to teach when i'm
unspeakably wet
we need to because of your presentation
on skateboarding
okay christy yeah pilgrim high school
yes first of all was your mascot
a pilgrim it was a pilgrim patriot no it
was a patriot
so you were the pilgrim patriots
which i'm not saying this out loud i
don't quite understand it but nobody we
weren't
pilgrims we were patriots i don't really
know
we did we we looked exactly like the
high school patriots
yes okay yes and our mascot looked like
a patriot like the new england patriots
it was just like a patriot
okay so there was no because when you
said the pilgrim patriots i thought it
was like a combination
like on the mayflower yeah so he has
like the hat
i wish it was i wish but no it was just
that we were just the patriots
um and you you think that i'd really i
haven't thought about that in so long
but i was
very spirited and so
like for pep rallies and things at our
school i would like and see
them like i had a lot of school spirit
so it's so ironic that the first
question you asked me is like what's
your mascot and i was like
i don't know
like if you would have been like the
history of the mascot is actually
extremely interesting
yeah we yeah we were the pilgrim
patriots
yep that was it what this is my
classic beginning of the pod question
but what flavor
of high school is pilgrim high school
like
where is it located public private
sports focused
theater felt like what what's the vibe
oh
so it was it was in the burbs
and it was public so we
i lived in warwick which is right
warwick rhode island which is right
outside of providence which is like the
big city
um but it was a public high school
not the nicest high school like i think
in terms of like
public schools like it was due for an
upgrade
um but and and yeah it was pretty i
think
it's interesting because we had some you
know there were some kids that were at
the school that were
more well off they lived in governor
francis which was like
the nice neighborhood that sounds like
it would be the nice neighborhood
i know governor francis it was the name
of like a neighborhood
and then and but then there were also k
you know kind of like me
and uh who who were definitely
like lower lower middle class or
um but lots of different walks of life i
think i graduated with
278 kids
okay so not a ton not a ton of people i
feel like it's not a huge i feel like
for a public school
i think my high school i actually you
know what i'm not even going to say
because i'm terrible at estimating
numbers and i have yeah
i don't actually watch it actually i
graduated with like thousands
i think it was only 270 something
i don't even think it was 300 so it was
kind of like i knew
pretty much everyone when it was
graduation time and they're walking
across the stage
i knew everyone and we all went to like
the same
middle school we called it a junior high
school it was just
seventh and eighth grade yes and then so
yeah it was aldridge junior high school
which no longer
exists and then we all went to pilgrim
together
so where did team christy fit
in the social world of pilgrim high
school
i was very popular
hell yeah like i was so and it's funny
yeah you were
i honestly i peaked so much in high
school it's funny because
earlier in my teens i went through a
very
awkward stage and then
later in high school i really
blossomed and so i was
i physically mentally emotionally peaked
in high school i was prom queen i had a
lot of friends
yeah and i was friendly though like i
won
i won a few superlatives but i was
friendliest that was the one i was very
like yeah
i think we have one of your superlatives
we have a photo
we can pull it out this we can look at
it in real time
i think this was my eighth grade so this
was right before high school
okay and you were and you got funniest
girls
so what do you think like earned you
funniest
girl definitely those bangs
i think that they took one look at the
bangs
uh on my face and that sweater vest
and said this girl's hysterical
definitely in eighth grade
was when i started i was it was
physically a very awkward time but i
started to sort of
yeah i would make a lot of joke it's
funny because i actually had a
friend at least named brittany who was
so so funny and sometimes she would say
things and i would just
repeat them and say them louder and then
everyone would laugh like i
said it oh no
[Music]
but i also like i did a lot of theater
and
i always was on stage so i think people
she was a lot
more shy and i was making some jokes but
like
i was just more outgoing britney really
should have won
brittany was your ghost writer in a way
for kind of your material at that time
she really was but i mean being funny
maybe it was the same for you in eighth
grade it's just like
quoting ace ventura like it's not like
you're coming up with
material it's like you're bending over
and talking out of your butt
and like that was oh wow christy's so
funny she can do ace ventura
so and also so if you were doing the
plays were you playing like the funny
part
in the play yes i was doing the funny
yes i did a lot of like
youth theater outside of high school and
then i would do things
in school so i would always do talent
shows or i would play the funny parts
and please
um that's another way to do it
and it was very outgoing yeah so that i
feel like that's
part like part of being funniest is sort
of a pr
campaign you have to wage for yourself
where it's like you've heard me on the
announcements
you've seen me in the pep rally
you have to get your material out to the
people like you have to hustle really
hard
i wish that i i was always so so funny i
was so
jealous of the girl who did the
announcements at school i wish that i
did the announcement
but aaron former guest on the pod did
the announcements
so we had one person who did the
announcements
uh that's that's important like you know
they had like a good voice
and they were confident with like
reading like welcome
students yeah assembly and yeah in the
auditorium
at fifth period like oh i would love to
have been that person at least i'm not
proud of this but i had a bit of an
attitude because i did theater
outside of my high school which was like
the youth theater like i
felt like my high school theater
was never as good as my feet are on the
side
so i would always you know i wasn't as
concerned
about the high school please because i
was like oh i'm
i'm doing summer theater like that's how
i i'm sure that like you telegraphed
that
to the other students oh they knew
they knew and i was such a [ __ ]
sometimes i was like i was really nice
but i'm actually i wanted to to tell you
about this and
i just have a couple i told you i was
friendliest and i
was friendly because i did drama club
so i was friends with a lot of like the
dorky
nerdy people and i also had a very
popular
boyfriend which made me very popular
but i have a couple of memories my
boyfriend
cheated on me in high school with a with
a
lower classman and i have memories where
i was
me and my friends were so mean
to this girl yes and i regret it i later
apologized to her because i was like i
was
mean and it's so funny because at the
time we're like oh we hate this girl
when really i should have been like my
boyfriend's
just as guilty if not or guilty
yeah i had that in in middle school and
high school too
i really internalized that like other
girls are your enemy
thing and having like really contentious
relationships with the other women in my
life and i'm
very glad to have shed that
100 in my life now and yeah
like truly if there are teenagers who
listen to this podcast
that is the one thing that i'm like
don't get into that other girls are your
friends
i know the other day be friends with all
of them like it's so
challenging and it's hard it's so hard
and i feel
awful for this girl and how you know i
it was funny because i never really
was the one spearheading these takedowns
but i wasn't stopping it i was kind of
just letting it happen
and also that's how it goes in high
school is like your friend
takes down underclassmen who kissed your
boyfriend
so that when someone needs to take her
person down
like you go around and do that and it's
like exactly
so how did the cheat go down like how
did you find
find out that it happened what where did
it happen
that's such a good question it happened
on a school
trip uh overseas they went to like
italy and it happened and then i came
back and he told me about it
and also it's high school so this
cheating's very like
pg it's like nothing yeah
so it's not like they went to italy and
they kissed
i was devastated oh of course but i kept
dating this guy
because he was like my boyfriend like we
had dated from
middle school up until he went to
college so it was like a significant
relationship
and oh yeah and and she
she was nice too and sweet and like
oh i remember i went up to her locker
one day and i told her that i knew
and i said to her and i'll never forget
what i said because i wasn't like that
this was big for me but i went up to her
and i said if i see you
talking to him and i said these words
verbatim
the [ __ ] is going to hit the fan
like i don't know i must have heard it
from like a tv show or something
i don't know where i came off saying
that i mean
that would have scared me like someone
walked up to me in high school and said
that to me i would be like
[ __ ] this girl's gonna clock me
i was so and one time like i went over
to his house after school and i saw she
messaged him on
aim and i was like you talked to her on
aim
like and it was a big like because that
was
you know we texted but a lot of our
communication was through
messaging oh and like the
i think i mean to this day the most
passionate
emotional communications i've ever had
were via
a i am like over the summer with a boy
i've talked to
one time and just like pouring my soul
out to this person and like the next
time i see him i'll be like okay
[Laughter]
that's so true one time over the summer
there was this really cute
boy that went to the all boys
high school and i so i had dated this
guy
pretty much all you know throughout my
teenage years but we
it was on and off we would break up and
during one of our off times there was
this like
heartthrob guy who now is like a country
artist living in nashville
but he uh i remember i was crushing on
him so bad that i
this summer there was a big carnival i
followed him around
i asked him for his phone number and
then he said
no but he'd give me his aim screen name
and i was like okay
i get i mean you know what like
i get it
aim is a more controllable thing maybe
he's got
like weird parents who monitor his
communications oh you would have been a
good friend i could have used you
at that at the carnival that i was out
oh no back then i would have been like
[ __ ] him
i'm gonna kick stuff
but yeah i guess about this trick i saw
on jackass christy i'm just
like looking horrible
on this trick oh but like that
i think that happening kind of sums up
my
personality i don't know where it came
from but i was
i had a lot of confidence as a teen in
my op
you know eighth grade ninth grade not so
much but i found it in high school and i
was really outgoing
were you friends with teachers like what
was your relationship with the
administrative
staff they either loved me loved me
loved me
or there were a few that did not like me
because i would talk back
um
really yeah i was like honestly i
i had i just had like an authority issue
obviously
based on literally everything i've laid
out about my teenage self i had an
authority problem and like
i like genuinely thought it was me and
my teacher asked me to do math
i was like this is actually [ __ ] up
it's 7
15.
and one time i did a school talent show
and i would do the talent show and i
would perform as britney spears
every year and one time we got to do it
during like a school assembly they chose
a couple acts and i did this britney
dance
and looking back it was pretty vulgar i
was like dry humping the ground
and then my math teacher was like does
your mother know
that you're doing those moves and then i
remember i said to her
my mother choreographed those moves even
though she didn't if i thought i was
going to come back
i was like she choreographed those moves
and then i got detention
because i talked my mom's a [ __ ] too
joke's on you we're a family of [ __ ]
and so you got detention for that for
saying your mom choreographed
the dance it was like talking back like
i talked back
and i did say it with an attitude i
could touch it a few times because i
would talk back
did you ever get like did you get in
trouble i got
in trouble i didn't get detention but i
feel like my high school
didn't do detention like that but i got
you out of the principal's office
did you that's that's even worse i did i
did well i was caught leaving which is
bad
that's bad okay that's like a big one
yeah i was caught leaving which is bad
but they let us just go back and then i
was just like rude
so i would always have like like i had
out an
ongoing issue with my algebra teacher
that ended up having to like
go to the principal's office to like
mediate between the two of us
like the relationship had devolved to
such a bad
point
other people had to step in
we're not saying eye to eye it got
really bad
it's really toxic between me and my
algebra teacher in 10th grade
because she would like ask you to solve
a problem and you were like
yes it was a man his name was mr hoobach
oh mr botched okay christy let's go
through some of the photos that you sent
i want to make sure that chat about them
the ones that we haven't already okay
oh my goodness this is a great one
is this prom oh this was
my freshman so i think
this one and then one other photo i sent
you were sort of like
pre transformation to a cool person
so this was like definitely my freshman
or sophomore year
um and i remember i borrowed this dress
because i normally didn't buy dresses
because i couldn't we couldn't really
afford them so i would
borrow people's dresses and i got my
hair done though and i remember thinking
it looked
crazy i want we need to break down this
style for the people who are listening
to the audio version so
let's say fully straight pin straight
full
frontal bangs complete
forehead straight bangs and then
um like a bouffant of curls
just the curl like a half up but picture
everything like a lion's
mane yes i showed the hair dresser
a photo of a lion and they said say no
more fam
and they just went to town it does the
curls are similar to
in wizard of oz when the lion gets his
hair done
oh my god it actually is
it looks just like that and like and
that's my
sweet date voodie who was a friend of
mine
okay no he was actually very popular
we both were popular despite what you
would look at and see
i think he has like a tasmanian devil
hitting a baseball tie
on which was which felt right to wear to
this dance
so wait this was actually a homecoming
dance we were friends
um and also look at in the background
this was our set decoration it's a
dead plant with clearly with lights on
it that aren't lit
christmas tree lights that are not lit
it's
probably put the lights up and they were
like oh you can't actually take pictures
in front of life
yeah like this is bad to have it backlit
these like awful silver drapes like
there's just
nothing right about this picture and
it's just
i i but i remember thinking that i had
never looked
more beautiful
you really look like a baby too like
you're so
yeah you it's a toddlers and tiara
energy
like and you're so dressed up
and like my braces which you can't
really tell but like
i just also didn't really know about
makeup so i just have like
bronzer yes and my braces which i had
braces for
like god for like about four years a
full amount of braces
uh but this was before and this that's
my natural hair color which is like
it looks brown but i guess it was like a
dark blonde it was just like
and i didn't have boobs like i just
developed so
rapidly and like afterwards
like was it one of those things where
like christy went away for the summer
and came back a woman
i think it kind of was
junior into into senior
mm-hmm i think that is at theater
like i just totally oh god
but i look at this and i'm just like wow
this this is so clearly a virgin
who is just trying her best you know
like yes and he looks so sweet too his
clothes are enormous
he's wearing huge clothes
i didn't even realize i could he said it
they're so big they're easily two-top
they're easily two or three sizes too
large
which was for style yeah style
it was like every boy i knew
just wore enormous clothes
like you can see on his arm
the the part of his shirt where his
shoulder should be
that's almost at his elbow like it's
just
it's the clothes are huge the pants are
huge
i remember being like wow voody looks
good
yeah like this was like my this is he
was so
sweet and he uh great everyone loved him
he looked just a sweet guy nice guy
friendly guy
so uh yeah this was fun this was our
homecoming dance
all right let's look at this next photo
here
okay this is fun you're in like uh
all denim i'm a denim
beast in this picture so this is
i think my senior year this is
gonna this girl very different
from the last girl isn't it insane that
if that's just like a year
or two years that's how different i love
the change like i mean this is crazy to
say but like
the change in your body your actual
physical body
is like oh right puberty
that's wild that's crazy
like the braces are off the hair is blot
my hair looks amazing your hair is
blonde now it's uh and it's long
and the hands are on layers the layers
are gone now i should describe this
outfit so
this was a hot night dance
which is so inappropriate i don't know
why we had them and everyone just
dressed
like like little strippers like that's
my
best friend kristen who you can see has
a dollar bill in her thumb
oh becca you can see she's a dollar bill
sponsored event oh yeah it was a hot
night dance so naturally i went to
rainbow shop
and bought a denim suit a denim
one-piece suit with a matching cowgirl
hat that says sexy
because that's what i was and there's
like silver graffiti on my denim
one-piece suit and i'm wearing platform
silver heels
yeah this i mean the girl before
virgin this girl [ __ ] fully i'm
the madam of a brothel
absolutely running like that's what i
did after drama club i'd go to my
brothel
and i would run [ __ ] and i i like it
yeah and that was
jim reynolds who i will tell both
kristen and jen
they'll definitely listen to the podcast
um he was
the and that he was not my boyfriend
again these are all men that weren't the
guy dated but
jim reynolds was the most popular
best looking athlete at the school and
you could tell like look at him you're
like this is a cool guy
yeah again he's like what is this denim
beast doing humping
dry humping me with reckless abandon and
you know what
his shirt fits his shirt is the right
damn size
that his arms right where it's supposed
to be this is a man
this is the man in his stride
and like you could tell you can look at
his arm like he's got hair
on that arm like jim he is a
man a man with clothes that fit them
with a clothes
outfit and we would kristen and i would
just she's my
best best best friend we would just we
were obsessed with jim
and we would we clearly were attack
teaming him
grinding on him the way i would grind
in front of the teachers who would
sponsor the dance
is beyond me i don't know what i was
thinking and i remember
you would grind on these high school
boys i remember
feeling boners yes and like not knowing
really what it was but kind of knowing
that
it was a boner but like yeah it was so
weird
also how surreal of an experience must
it have been to like
be a chaperone at these dances and these
kids are just like like rubbing their
genitals on each other and it's like
okay what point do we stop them
are we gonna let them come or what's
happening here
like
it's so true i just we were so
i was so inappropriate i get and clearly
i get embarrassed when i look
back and see how much
i how just i crossed the line
so many times like i really truly did
but
this was the night like just the thought
like even kristen like she wore like a
cute
tube top and like a skirt and then
something within me said no no
don't do that christy get a denim
cowgirl suit
it's hot night though it's hot night it
was a hot
night and i was like you know what i
love a theme don't threaten me with a
theme
because i'm gonna cowgirl hat
[Laughter]
all right so let's talk about the end
the end of high school for you so
how was your like college search
process who did you when you were
christy's walking across
the stage at graduation who did you
understand yourself to be
what was your like oh god that's a great
so i was my whole life
hell on moving to new york city after
high school
and i had auditioned and applied
to go to different schools in new york
and that's all i wanted was to come to
new york city
and i remember hearing my mom and dad
one night
talk about i remember it was like mary
mount manhattan i wanted to go to or
like
wagner college or nyu and these are all
schools that i tried out for
and and i remember i heard my mom and
dad talking about
how difficult it would be for them
and how and my mom was saying that maybe
they could like
refinance the house and i remember they
were really upset
just getting emotional being
disappointed
because they knew how much it meant to
me so i
pretended like i did like i changed my
mind
and i went to i went i had a
scholarship to go to the university of
rhode island
which i went to for 20 minutes
until i dropped out and then i i worked
a bunch of full-time jobs and ended up
paying my own way
and i moved to the city when i was nine
when i was like 19 and a half
oh my god that's an incredible
story first of all that's so sweet
that's such like a precious mom i mean a
precious and a sad
moment what was it that you hated about
university of rhode island just
everything
everything i just never wanted to be
there and it's funny because i remember
going to the orientation and liking it
and then i got a part in the play
and everyone in the theater department
was so mad because
freshmen shouldn't get parts and because
i got a part this girl that was a senior
didn't get a part in there in her last
musical so everyone
hated me and i hated it and i was like
this is
i went home for thanksgiving and never
went back
so i truly went to school for 13 months
that oh that's wild
so when you were did you did you go to
school in the city when you
got to new york i did so i went to
an acting school the american musical
and dramatic academy
oh okay and uh which is
i went there for a few years and also
dropped out so dropping out has become
a bit of a thing that i'm famous for um
but yeah but i always i knew i wanted
to be an actress on broadway that was
what
my goal was always in high school when i
was younger
everything was about being on broadway
and doing musicals that was like
all i knew i did musicals what was your
favorite musical that you did
in high school um
we would constantly choose
terrible musicals to do like i was
dorothy in
our high school's entirely caucasian
production
of the wiz oh my god i thought you were
going to say wizard of oz and then you
were like entirely caucasian i'm like oh
no it's happening oh it's bad like we
had no business doing these shows but
so i was um oh actually audrey in little
shop of horrors
oh that's such a good part such a good
card
somewhere that's right is so fun to say
that was like my song that i would sing
to get into
you know if i ever needed a song to sing
for anything i would i would sing that
song and i yeah
but yeah but i'm 35 and i've been in new
york now since i was 19.
wow that's wild i feel like
what is that like to be in new york as a
19 year old
i look back it's so exciting but i was
so
naive and i think to myself now
how lucky i was that i didn't get
kidnapped and taken
and roofied and killed there were so
many situations where i was like i was
way too trusting of people i was
very stupid i think i made a lot of
stupid decisions but i think somebody
was definitely looking out for me
yeah okay christy this has been an
amazing episode i'm gonna ask you
the last question that i asked all of
our guests
um and that is if you could talk to
team christy today what would you tell
her
i would tell her that
oh god that's such a good question um
this is when the people always cry in
encore
[Laughter]
encore that's when they cry you know my
brain went to sort of
two things so i'll kind of talk through
it i think the first would be
something that i wish i were better at
now that sort of started for me then
which was worrying and anxiety like my
teachers would call me like a worry wart
when i was in high school and i would
kind of just laugh at it but i
look back and that was sort of the start
of i'm very
over analytical and i do have a lot of
anxiety so i think that i would
look back and try to tell myself
especially
as a teen that you're gonna have your
whole life to worry about things
and that you don't need to take
everything quite as seriously
as you were taking it and and to sort of
lighten up a little bit
um and just you know for better or worse
just sort of like a reminder that it's
it's temporary like if anyone's
listening that is in high school or
younger like
whether you could be the belle of the
ball or you could be somebody who eats
their
lunch in the bathroom but like it really
doesn't matter
because it's not it's not the real world
and it's
temporary and you will come out of it
and then you will be able to be whoever
you want to be
you can reinvent yourself a million
times in life
and i i think that that's like a cool
thing to know
yeah that's it's so interesting the way
that when you're in high school
it feels like i mean it feels like this
enormous chunk of your life because it
is
at that time and then now that i'm 30
it's like the smallest
little blip of time that happened but
when i remember
i remember then time felt so long like a
single school year felt like
so much so much has happened
i know i remember just like looking at
the clock and feeling like the days
lasted so long and thinking like oh my
my birthday's in two weeks that's
forever
like and now it's like i think
especially this year with the [ __ ]
pandemic and everything but it just goes
by so quickly
and yeah it's not
yeah it's it's so it's so nuts i get
very nostalgic like i get happy when i
think about
my high school years but um but but
but you know i think i'd also say too
that i like
getting older yeah and don't be scared
about it
like don't be like oh no like i used to
be like oh like 25 like what a grandma
but it's great you learn about yourself
and you know you give less of a [ __ ]
every day
i really do feel like i i turned 30 in
may like during the pandemic and
i do feel like a switch flipped uh like
in my brain
of not giving a [ __ ] about stuff that
really
put took a huge mental toll on me
like a year or two prior i'm so happy to
hear that honestly at least that was
sort of my experience like it wasn't
until i was maybe 30 or 31 or even 32.
like i remember being in my late 20s and
being very different and yeah having a
real change happen so
i thought like frantic feeling of like
what am i doing what's everyone else
doing where am i going
etc like something it's not like i never
feel like that anymore but like
there was a slowdown that happened good
i'm so happy to hear that i know maybe
it's that thing of like well i can't be
on
any of these lists of young people
anymore so i don't need to
worry about it i'm not gonna be on this
stupid list
it's happened i remember having a
feeling when i
got out of high school that i was like
well i'm never
gonna get pregnant in high school like
it happened i made it
i didn't get pregnant i made it through
that one
yes yes you know and i think that even
being a comedian i think that
more so and this might be a little naive
too but i think more so than
other professions there's a lot about
our industry
or the entertainment industry that feels
like high school sometimes oh yeah
whether it's like the lists and the
popularity contest and there is this
kind of
thinking of what's that what's this
person doing and that and like
influencing yeah
so and parties and events that are like
social slash
professional and yeah what's going on
yeah sometimes i just wish that i could
just like be a hairdresser and just like
go to hairdresser sure that [ __ ] is
happening there too that's i know that's
what i tell myself it's like you know i
always feel like
we're so unique but it's like it happens
everywhere it really does
i know all right i feel like that's a
perfect place for us to end it kristy
you were an amazing guest it was so
great chatting with you
and for everybody listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
[Music]
podcast
you